let's take some phone calls our phone
number is six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty that's the number and
we'll go to our first caller in the six
one three area code caller what's your
name and where you're calling from hi
David my name is Matt I'm from Ontario
Canada great what's on your mind there's
a few things I'd like to talk to you
about I'll click one of course notes
phone call um so one of which might be
the James Comey FBI debacle at the end
of the election I do want to talk about
that was you so it seemed like you were
pretty from what I remember you're
pretty upset with the way that the
supposed reopening of the investigation
went about yeah well it there was not a
clear explanation as to why on the one
hand multiple times we heard from Comey
that the FBI doesn't comment about the
existence or lack of existence of
investigations yet we had two letters in
a press conference from Comey about
exactly that with regard to hillary
clinton at times that were undoubtedly
damaging to her candidacy that that's
true but do you not agree that James
Comey should have supplemented his
record in terms of what he said under
oath when he was being deposed or
whatever you would call that you're
saying in other words that when James
Comey publicly said that he couldn't say
whether an investigation did or didn't
exist that off the off the record or in
other words privately he could have
supplemented that with information about
an investigation to the people on the
panel questioning him is that your idea
no it's more that the facts changed
after he was under oath and should he
not not have supplemented the record
when the facts changed which they did
when the Anthony Weiner investigation
when it was discovered that you know
there were tons of emails related to
Hillary Clinton there but there were but
there weren't here's so here's the key
thing what he did was he said we now
that we have more emails we're going to
look into whether any of these have any
relevance to our investigation into
Hillary Clinton what you're saying he
said he didn't say you're saying that
what he said was hey there are emails
here relevant
investigation of Hillary Clinton that's
not what he said he just said hey now
that we have more stuff to look at I'm
gonna mention Hillary Clinton and by the
way if anything's related then we're
gonna come back and talk to you again
but that that that's what he said is not
what you're saying he said if I remember
correctly though they were able to
identify that some of the emails had
originated or transferred through the
server though is that not the case I
don't remember that what I do remember
is that because Anthony Weiner was at
the time married to Hillary Clinton's
aide humi abaddon that there were there
were email chains in all of those emails
that were you know in some way connected
to both Hillary Clinton and humor but
that's because Anthony Weiner is married
to her that's just sort of obvious okay
and but but again like so so let's get
beyond that I guess but so they did come
out before the election I think a couple
days and actually completely clear her
name like yes very good by the time 30%
of the vote had been done yes when 30 to
35 percent of people had voted James
Comey came out and said oh so now we're
actually done you're right about that
okay yeah what's your point god James
Comey did something wrong is it that he
did something right what what's your
point no my point that my points that
like I think there was a bit of an
overreaction to him essentially feeling
the need to come and supplement his
statements under oath that he felt were
no longer true at the time so when he
came to supplement the record I feel
like that was him saying what I said is
no longer applicable because I don't
know that that's the case and since
that's the case and considering we're
about to have a presidential election it
would be wrong as me not to supplement
that yeah no I totally disagree with you
I totally disagree with you on the on
the one hand the supplement was an
irrelevant supplement because he didn't
actually have anything to say right he
said we're gonna look to see whether
there is even anything to supplement and
he'd never should have done the original
letter press conference in the first
place so I think we just disagree on
that but I do appreciate you calling in